so a linked list is kind of the first
serious data talks you learn about
because it's very simple and it's
actually got structure when rains got a
bit for october link list is kind of
slightly more complex we consume some
flourishing things of the link list so a
linked list is made up of nodes each
node stalls and items data so it could
be a number it will be in our example
this is easy to write and it has a
reference to the next node in the list
if we wanted to store the numbers 1 2 3
& 4 in a linked list it would look
something like this each node stores a
value and a pointer to the next node so
the value is 1 then we have another node
with 2 in it and the first one point to
the second one and if we want to have 3
we can fire where do you put the link is
it in the new single or is it no if
you're adding things at the end of the
list the link goes from the existing
node to the new node if you're adding
things at the start to list which you
can do you can't do it with an array
because where do you put it you've got
nothing you don't have access to what's
before that in memory you know you're
going to trample over something else and
cause problems if you want to know that
starts with linked lists so you want to
add 0 to this list we could just create
a new node somewhere it's not aware in
memory actually is they don't need to be
next each other these arrows can point
to anywhere else in memory but if we
wants to add the node 0 to the start of
this list we'd create a new node put 0
in it and then point it at this element
so now if we have two special nodes we
have one called the head and one called
the tail so the head is the node at the
start of the list that points to
everything else the tail is the nose at
the end of lips that is pointed to by
previous nodes and points to nowhere in
general you would link list you need to
keep track of at least the head the tail
is kind of optional you don't have a
keep track of the tail necessarily but
if node it's going to be the head of our
linked list so we'll have a some
reference somewhere probably a you know
as variable called head that points
so this node so if we want to find
things in the list we can go to the head
and then we look at its next pointer and
this one's next pointer little next
pointer the last element in a linked
list the tail of this you'll notice is
some point anywhere conceptually there
needs to be some value here we can't
leave it uninitialized memory because it
will be a garbagey number it will point
to somewhere who knows where in memory
and if you follow that link and try and
interpret it as a node you're probably
going to make your program crash what we
do is we we point out that null so in C
or Java it's called null or I'll be the
number 0 like a memory address 0 which
is interpreters null or in Python it
would be none I think it's I think it's
null in most languages if I know it
points to null then we know it's the
last item in the list which is nice we
know when we know we've gone through the
whole list and found every element kind
of reminds me little bit of a sort of
Treasure Trail where you find something
and then it tells you where to go next
yeah I guess is like that so yeah I mean
similarly to that you can't you can't
find a middle clue without having to
find one before it so with a link layer
you don't have random access or constant
time random access to the element so if
you wanted to find the last one element
in the list you need to start from the
start
keep counting forward probably until you
get the last one and then oh it's gone
before that
I mean if you want to get to the 10th
element you have to go through 10 times
so in a row you can access the 10th
element really easily you just say get
the element n it multipliers the width
of the variable or the width of the item
by 10 and jumps that far in memory with
a linked list you can't do that because
they're stored in arbitrary places in
memory you don't really know where and
you can only get to them by following
the link so this intense thing you've
got Paulo's handling thousands thing
you've got the follow-up out of the link
because they could be buried anywhere in
however many gigabytes of RAM on your
computer so yeah these could be anywhere
in memory you could be jumping around
all over the place yeah that's the only
way to get there is to follow the link
sometimes we might also want to maintain
a reference to the tail as well as the
head so we can just point tail at this
last element and this helps us if we
want to add elements to the end of the
linked list because if we know where
this node is we can stop it pointing at
null and point a new node and then point
the new node at Mel's what happens if
you need to have something in the middle
of the list oh let's say we wanted to
add the number 26 in between 1 and 2 so
you know who knows why but we want to do
it so what we need to do is create a new
node somewhere matter let's let's put it
here that contains the number 26 we need
to break this link so that's no longer
there and we add two new ones one
pointing from the node 126 another one
point from no 26 to 2 if we wanted to do
this in an array what we have to do is
we'd have to shift every element after
one down one that will take and
operations and then put the number 26 in
the gap we just made by moving a tool on
so with a linked list after we found the
place we want to insert the node it's
constant time assertions at least we're
breaking one link and creating three
more and that subtle how many knows
there are in the list we're changing
three links breaking one adding two
searching may take up to in it if we
want to insert after an element with a
value of 3 we're gonna have to search
through the whole list and that will
take up to n so after those up to the
number of things in the list the actual
insertion is constant time
also if you want to remove an element
from the list that's that quite easy to
what we do we would we break these two
links and then we create a new link
joining one two two again so the flight
special case for inserting or removing
if you want to do it at the head or the
tail you need to change the head or tail
reference points of the new nose
please the head or tail so if we want to
remove the first node in the list we
break this link we would break this link
and then we create a new link from head
to the new head of the list similarly if
we insert we point a head at the new
node if we delete the tail we point tail
at that node create a new one we point
it at the new know these linked lists
we've looked at so far are called singly
linked Lee because they each have a
single link to the next node in the list
now there are also stubbly linked lists
so a doubly linked list has a link both
to the next node and the previous node
so those are slightly different
they now have three compartments okay so
we have the value still here so we've
got 0 1 2 3 each of these as a point of
votes to the next node and to the
previous node so
three here and of course not getting
okay no that goes the no seeing kind of
thing is it's a breadcrumb trail but it
goes both ways so if you want to you can
start at the head and go down to the
tail you can start the tail and work
throughout so the head still you don't
have very good random access because
you've either got to go from the tail
and backwards or from the head and
forward okay so a practical example of
where I've actually used a doubly linked
list in almost the real world in your
web browser you visit website you click
some link you go to the next page next
page next page and then in the top
corner you can click the back button and
go back a bit keep going back so you can
go forwards again and then also you
might go back a bit you might click
another link let's see how this works
for the link list I'm just going to all
the data compartments is easier so we
start with main page at the start of a
list this just points the null this will
also point to null as soon as we browse
to somewhere so yesterday I was looking
up on Wikipedia and it was linked to
nothing on the front page so I went to
look at NASA so it's points back from
here this points to null because we're
browsing NASA and then really bit about
NASA click on the Neil Armstrong article
it points back here and points forward
to null because it's the end of the list
from Neil Armstrong I started reading
about Apollo 11 so points back to Neil
Armstrong and forwards the null so while
we're going forward we know which page
were on so we're on Apollo 11
so if we're pointing out Apollo 11 here
is my hastily constructed non blow away
able pointer so I think enough about
Apollo 11 I'm going to go back a couple
of so go back to Neil Armstrong now
we're reading about Neil Armstrong again
so on his page you know if you wants me
to go forward to Apollo 11 click forward
button but okay we go back a couple back
to NASA our black history is still there
or forward history is still there
however we decide to take another link
on NASA we decide to look at the
International Space Station page so
there's a link from NASA to the IFF page
for the click there now we break this
link we no longer have Nia long
stroganoff forward history we're now ISS
pointing back to NASA and if we go back
to NASA from ISS we're at where I
assessed we go back to NASA we can't get
back to the alarm stron anymore
we have no no way to get there every
time we're on a page and we click a new
hyperlink we break
the previous history the previous port
it's big goes away and we create a new
nodes that that represents the current
page rom are the many other things that
sort of code gets useful yeah so you
might do this with something like undo
and redo history in a program like word
or or notepad or something like that
some saw mentor every time you take one
do you go back to previous takes but
your redo states still there until you
do something and then you've lost
through your redo history aleko using
something like sure we like vim which I
think sauce all your undo and redo is a
tree and you can eventually get back to
the things so it doesn't ever throw
anything away
but but for most ones would you say it's
breaking the chain yeah so you break the
chain you throw away all this future
that you you've gone back from and it's
gone so look at the names and make the
names meaningful so instead of doing
that you can use a thing called an array
which is one name that points up
multiple items of data which we saw next
to each other and a contiguous block of
memory